ah i won't have to talk about my very
complicated feelings about clara for a
long time after this one
oh that's nice
[Music]
hey folks i finished up my series 9
re-watch so that means
i gotta rank these but before i can even
get to it i do have to
specify a few things because i had to
figure out how i was going to do these
now normally when i do rankings like
this i
lump two parters as one story but the
thing is some of the two-parters
or in some case arguably three parters
in this particular series
are a little bit weird in a way that i
didn't feel comfortable
lumping them together so for example
you have the girl who died and the woman
who lived
now one is definitely a sequel to the
other but i don't consider them to be a
two-parter because
this is usually about the first one more
than the second
but in the case of both episodes they
have complete stories they have complete
arcs they climax they resolve
one follows on from the other but that's
not really a two-parter to me a
two-parter
it needs to be a case of the story isn't
done
not there's more to tell but like this
is an unfinished story
you could never watch just the one half
and feel like you had a full experience
that also means on the same basis face
the raven hell bent heaven sent
all three of those i am going to be
dealing with separately i know they
connect
but each one has its own arc has its own
conclusion has its own climax is a
complete
experience even though there are threats
to pick up later so
you don't agree with me tough it's my
list here we go
bottom of the barrel
number nine
sleep no more
you thought it was going to be hell bent
didn't you well see
here's the thing despite everything
about hell bent and how much the things
that i don't like about it i
really really
don't like about it there are still some
things that work or there are things
that at the very least i can look at
some of the core concepts
or the ideas that play and go that could
have worked
there was potential there i look at
sleep no more and you know what
i got nothing the few things that it's
doing it's like i don't see the merit
in that right from the start with the
visual gimmick
of the first person and and um security
camera perspective
it doesn't add anything the story isn't
built around being told that way
it is an absolute gimmick and adds
nothing to the story the story itself is
not particularly interesting i don't
think the monsters are effective at all
the ending is this cheap ooh
is the horror really over thing that
means nothing there are really no
elements at play in this episode where i
go oh that bit though i'm pretty much
like no
get out of here
number eight
now it's time for hellbent so yeah hell
bent was always going to come in low on
this list because
well as evidenced by the fact that i
started that review
thinking i was going to be able to talk
about it more calmly than i have in the
past and ultimately working myself
up about as much as i've ever been
worked up about that episode yeah i
still really don't like it and honestly
i feel a little bit bad about that
because i've talked to people
who not only like it i've talked to
people who used to dislike it but have
come around on it and i wish i could
i would much rather like it than hate it
but i'm sorry
i still hate it i hate what it's doing
and i hate the way that it does it i
don't think it
fully properly executes what's it's what
it's trying to do
and then i don't like what it's trying
to do in the first place so
for my measure aside from a couple of
like little blips of interesting ideas
here and there
i don't think it does a good job
executing what's trying to do and i
don't think the thing is trying to do is
worth doing in the first place so
what else do you expect from me
number seven
zion invasion zygon inversion two-parter
this placement might be
a little bit controversial but look can
i be completely honest with you
other than that speech at the end which
kills
i don't really like too much about this
two-parter the first half especially is
a mess
it's it's a lot of logistical problems
and the flow is
not great even the second part while
it's
going a little bit better overall and
like i said the tail end of it and the
speed
i mean the speech is why the whole thing
is you know isn't
well i was going to say isn't closer to
the bottom even if it didn't have the
speech it wouldn't have been below hell
bent and
sleep no more but look i just think that
that speech
while amazing and i will happily rewatch
that
anytime the package that it comes in
i just don't think it's that good it i
get what it's trying to do but i don't
think it pulls it off
number six the woman who
lived my issues with this one i'll
largely have to do with just
it's the elements don't fully gel
like i actually find what's going on
with the shields are really interesting
in terms of what they're doing with her
and the implications and what it means
for a human
who was never you know a species that
was never designed to live this long
is living this long and sort of digging
into what that really means
for her for her life experience but
then the whole thing with the thundercat
looking
dude and everything else i'm like this
the pieces don't quite
fit together right on this one so
despite some good moments and some solid
performances it just kind of ends up
being yes
it's okay
number five
the magician's apprentice and the witch
is familiar
so this one is got some hiccups in it i
have mixed feelings about
ultimately the fact that davoros is
trying to trick the doctor and all of
that because i feel like it undercuts
some really strong stuff done prior to
that
but you know this like i said the stuff
right under that was really strong
that cold open on the first one is
amazing and
missy missy is so much fun in this
it is stellar michelle gomez is owning
this i
really wanted that pointy stick to be a
running thing but
i just she the way she messes with
clara and messes with the doctor and
teases the daleks
ah like in my mind this is almost more
of a missy story than anything else
because
at the very least that's what i come
away going yeah about it the most
number four
the girl who died so this one i put
above
the woman who lived largely owing to
where things go on the tail end in terms
of what it brings out about the doctor
and his realization of where the face
comes from
and the significance that is given to
that that's that bit
i was gonna say speech it's probably not
enough to qualify as a speech though i
did put it on my top 10 speeches list i
love
i love what that moment means for this
doctor in terms of coming into his own
because i love
this health doctor's arc over his three
series i absolutely adore it and this is
a real pivotal moment in that
and the rest of what's going on is
pretty good but you know what this
episode has
it has a lot of great banter i
love the doctor like trying to prep
these villagers to
you know be able to take on these aliens
and the
little snippets of advice and the the
lines about how he just gives everyone
nicknames
because he can't be bothered to learn
their real lives i love the interactions
the plot is
fine but it's the interactions and that
bit at the end it
brings it up to yeah pretty good
number three
face the raven look this is a really
good exit for clara it's an amazing
culmination of where things have been
going
for her not only over the course of the
series but also prior to this
despite the fact that series a was not
designed with the intention that clark
was going to continue on into series 9
and then have the exit that she did
they picked up on things that were
already going on
in series 8 and brought them forward
into series 9
to bring it to this conclusion
everything that is going on with her
getting
too comfortable with these scenarios
getting cocky thinking that she can be
like the doctor and making a fatal error
and the impact of that the way that she
comes to
some degree of acceptance of that but at
the same time the episode does not
chicken out and be like
and she went peacefully like no this
hurts
this is not pleasant for her yes she
faced it bravely but
no this sucks sucks for her it sucks for
everybody
the only reason i'm not gonna go higher
than three on it has to do with things
like the
the the street the the hidden street
thing and
things going on there like that's a
really interesting idea
that doesn't really get explored here
i'm not sure that it needed more time
devoted
to it because where the time does alec
does get allocated makes more sense but
it does leave me going
that's an idea you that i kind of wish
you had stuck into an episode where that
could have been more of the
focus you know this mashup of this
mix of aliens so like it's a setting
that i wish
either had a story that was more about
the place or was the setting that i wish
came back
i don't just mean getting redressed for
husbands of river's song
number two
under the lake and before the flood this
is a really strong two-parter
and it does a really good job building
the mystery and building the tension
because you're seeing these ghosts and
it's like what is going on and and what
i really like about it is
these are clearly something to do with
the fact that these people are now dead
but it never tries to play like oh it's
really ghost because one of my recurring
things that
not necessarily annoyed by but i
definitely do make fun of on doctor who
is the
oh it's this mythological or folklore or
superstition thing and then it's like oh
no it's aliens here clearly there's
something else going on
it never tries to sell that the ghosts
are actually ghosts
they have too many restrictions they're
behaving too weird something else has to
be at play
so it doesn't try to be like oh but
they're not really ghosts there's
something else
which is smart because if you watch
doctor who at all you already knew that
but it's just really well put together
the look on the fisher king is great
and the the doctor and the tension with
with him in terms of him getting excited
about what's going on but then having to
face the fact that more of these people
are going to die and he knows it and he
can't do anything about it
and the stuff that goes on they they do
some really interesting things with the
with the deaf character uh oh god the
tension in that scene was
dragging loudly this axe behind her and
she can't hear us like oh my
god there's some really good tension
it's really well paced
there's a good build to the whole thing
and it's even got some cute and fun
moments in it as well so yeah this is a
really good
and well put together piece and number
one to the surprise of
literally nobody heaven sent
oh boy i mean what
what else is there for me to say about
this episode it's
beautiful it is fantastically put
together it is so
sure of itself it there's so much
confidence in doing a
very non-standard doctor who story
in terms of the fact that the doctor has
no one else to talk with
the monster it's debatable whether it is
even really a monster it's just
him talking to himself or to this vision
of clara
he has it's but it's just him on his own
trying to figure this stuff out
that's ballsy and this thing goes
forward with confidence which you need
to if you're going to try and do that
and that's even before you get into the
metaphorical and allegorical stuff about
grief about loss about trying to process
and how trying to do that can feel like
you're just chipping away
at something that is you're never gonna
get through
but maybe someday you will and you can
and oh my god the emotional
rollercoaster
of the last few minutes of this thing i
i can't ever fully recapture it because
seeing it but i can remember seeing it
for the first time
that sinking feeling of how long he'd
been there not knowing how he's gonna
come out and then the absolute triumph
realizing what he was doing and that it
was gonna work i
adore this episode
so much and that's my ranking for series
9.
how would you put these in what order
how badly do you think
i screwed up whatever your thoughts are
drop them down in the comments let's
talk about it i have a patreon
which helps keep this whole thing going
and offers perks and rewards to those
who wish to lend me any level of support
but even if you're not able to do that
liking sharing subscribing all of which
also help me out so i'd appreciate that
as well but you don't
have to do any of it because at the end
of the day you are the council
i just run the meetings and until next
time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
hmm
[Music]
um